le tour volleyball justement Lucas on va
en parler avec notre invité ce soir oui
nous recevons ce soir François Bruno il
est le nouveau président du TVB après
une carrière de chef d'entreprise à la
tête d'axom propreté pendant 17 ans il
est arrivé à la tête des stars du volet
tourano au mois de juin dernier il va
donc nous parler de la direction qu'il
souhaite donner au club bonsoir François
Bruno bonsoir soyez le bienvenu sur
notre plateau d'abord une réaction au
résultats on vient de de de l'entendre
les résultats de de votre équipe en ce
début de saison trois matchs de ligue à
joué deux défaites elle est compliquée
cette entame c'est vrai que le début de
saison est un peu compliqué je voulais
quand même rappeler la victoire sur le
premier match en Supercoupe puisquon a
déjà remporté un trophée pour cette
année
2023 donc ça se ça se ça suit le
championnat qu'on a gagné l'année
dernière donc malgré tout c'est vrai un
début d'entâ compliqué alors je rappelle
on a fait un petit peu une cure de
juvance en en début de saison puisqu'on
a misé sur de jeunes internationaux
français qui font le le jeu arrière du
du club et qui doivent prendre un petit
peu leur marque le temps de lancer le
jeu que on sait retrouver à la salle
Grenon et quand un président vient
d'arriver comme vous est-ce qu' peut
encore changer les choses pour cette
saison est-ce que tout est arrêter
est-ce que vous avez encore la main sur
quelques petites choses pour la saison à
venir alors bien sûr au niveau du du
recrutement sportif sauf qu'à compliqué
de pépin physique euh on va rester sur
cette équipe hein qui composé de de 16
joueurs euh qui nous permet je pense
d'avoir la capacité à jouer les premiers
rôles du championnat on va jouer
également la Champions League je
rappelle où là notre notre ambition est
un peu moins importante mais qui permet
aussi de donner du temps de jeu à nos
jeunes joueurs et c'est quand même une
année de transition euh qui va nous
permettre aussi de faire part nos
ambitions
pour le championnat français et puis la
Coupe de France aussi quelles sont-elles
alors ses ambitions le top bien sûr
alors vous savez qu'on joue les
play-offs hein donc il faut essayer de
finir dans les premières places du
championnat pour autant après il faut
encore jouer les play-offs et être bon
je dirais à la fin donc même si le début
de saison est un peu compliqué c'est à
la fin qu'on verra les les vrais
résultats de notre on va dire nos
options choisies pour le recrutement et
ça se jouera au mois de avril hein c'est
c'est là que je vous rappelle la saison
est assez concentrée puisque on a
commencé tard à champion on finit tôt he
et on finit tôt parce que les Jeux
Olympiques qui arrivent donc c'est très
réduit avec beaucoup d'port pour les
Jeux Olympiques quand même effectivement
puisque on a des des des très très bons
joueurs alors parlons un peu du de
l'avenir de votre de votre présidence
vous souhaitez pas travailler seul si
j'ai bien compris ça va être une
véritable équipe entre les amateurs et
les professionnels également oui je je
rappelle le TVB est donc adossé à une
association amateur et depuis 2 ans
enfin après la période covid pendant la
période covid pardon on a créé une
société professionnelle les deux sont
solidaires et et fonctionnent ensemble
puisque par exemple le centre de
formation est adossé à à la au monde
amateur et certains jeunes qui composent
l'équipe viennent du centre de formation
de tour pour autant dans le travail il
faut faire un travail d'équipe alors
j'ai bien sûr un comité directeur qu'on
qu'on a renforcé et qui va pouvoir
s'étauffer lors de la prochaine AG qu'
aura lieu 17 novembre prochain et puis
c'est un travail de gouvernance entre
ces deux entités pour qu'on travaille en
management de projet de façon à monter
des actions sur du court terme pour des
choses qu'on va faire sur ce championnat
là et puis pour commencer à travailler
sur la saison prochaine et puis il y a
le développement aussi de de la
recherche des partenaires privés on a
tous en tête l'affaire du naming
McDonald's ça veut pas dire qu'il y aura
plus de partenaires privés bien sûr
alors le le partenairat privé se résume
pas au naming naming c'est un outil
c'est une possibilité de lever de façon
un peu plus importante des fonds privés
mais c'est vrai que comme le la partie
institutionnelle je dirais est plutôt
stable au niveau des investissements on
doit si on veut se développer aller
chercher de nouveaux partenaires alors
par le naming mais aussi par des
partenaires privé on on en compte déjà
plus de 180 au sein de du groupe de TVB
entreprise et c'est ces partenaires
privés qui nous permettront de nous
développer dans les prochaines années un
mot rapide pour terminer on sait que
d'ici quelques mois Pascal Foussard
manager de l'équipe prendra sa retraite
faut penser à la relève j'imagine oui on
est c'est en cours bien sûr euh donc
Pascal prend sa retraite au mois de juin
2024 euh on a déjà j'ai déjà rencontré
des candidats l'idée est de pouvoir
finaliser un recrutement pour la fin
d'année dirais le mois de décembre euh
on pourra malheureusement pas vous
donner de nom Ah bah non il faudra
revenir mais il y a aussi l'option que
Pascal reste en soutien en consant
consultant pour n faire part de son
expérience parce que remplacer Pascal
Foussard avec 40 ans d'expérience pas
une chose j'ai pas trouvé sur le marché
pour le moment on a on a toute confiance
en vous euh pour cela merci beaucoup
François Bruno d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci
bonsoir